all right before we get to the
werewolves it's a solid cross promotion
of a deuces on myself want to thank the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by crowd cow crab cow is
an online marketplace that ensures that
you can get high quality meat and know
exactly where your food's coming from
just go on their website shop for high
quality beef pork chicken seafood and
more you can buy meat that's grass-fed
pasture-fed or wild-caught their meat
has no growth hormones or unnecessary
antibiotics a completely unbeatable
selection here it's like a haven for my
fellow carnivores
and meat of sources each cut is vacuum
sealed and frozen at the peak of
freshness so click the link below go to
crowdcow.com
jeremy get 15 off your first order you
can also save an extra 5
off of everything when you become a
member click the link below membership
is free and thank you once again to
crowd cow for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it alright we've talked about
the cow
now let's talk about the wolves the
werewolves
[Music]
stephen king's silver bullet so silver
bullet came out in 1985
it's a werewolf movie it's a mystery
movie it's a mystery movie about who's
the werewolf and it's very stephen king
also a movie that scared the living hell
out of me i saw this movie before i saw
jaws i was a little kid and it was the
movie where i was like okay i'm sleeping
under my covers for a month and i mean
under my covers like you know
how people sleep under the covers no i
mean the covers
are a magical force field that keeps the
werewolf away
and i sleep with my head under it and
now i gotta choose because
oxygen depletion is a thing as you're
breathing under the cover so do i want
to poke my head out and
take a breath and take a chance that i'm
going to come face to face with the
werewolf or do i just keep my head
underneath so i would do that thing
where you just make a hole you're like
for a
solid month after watching silver bullet
scared me to death for the characters in
this movie the ones i love like gary
busey as the uncle he's the alcoholic
self-destructive yet cool to his nephew
and niece uncle i mean there's an ark
with him at a point he stops drinking
it's like his
nephew going hey there's a werewolf out
there and he's like all right well i'll
help you out i guess if i kind of
believe you which i do kind of believe
you
it causes him to stop drinking and being
so self-destructive but it's
you got to pay attention to it it's not
like anyone's like hey you stopped
drinking i'm really proud of you there's
a solid arc with him but he's also
amazing as a cool uncle he's just he
feels like the kind of uncle you want to
have as an uncle he's really cool for
his paraplegic nephew he'll build him
this
rocket wheelchair that's completely not
within code and we'll probably get the
kid killed and it's so easy to see gary
busey is
just the crazy guy it's like oh it's
crazy gary busey but
dude has a catalog of performances and
roles in movies where
he's a really good actor i thought he
crushes it as the uncle in silver bullet
also the late corey haim in his youth
he's a paraplegic kid who starts being
like wait a minute
i think there's a werewolf in this town
so he is the star of the show as
true stephen king's small town and in
that stephen king way this movie really
does concentrate on the small town drama
and hey
there's this supernatural element that's
rearing its head and
none of the adults believe there's a
supernatural thing that's why a kid in a
stephen king's story like this is so
important because like
kids they have the imagination to take
that leap like
most of the time in the real world
they're just kids being kids with
imaginations and they're ridiculous and
that's why
we defer to the adult opinions but there
have been enough stephen king stories
out there that show that in a stephen
king story like this the kids are the
ones who have the imagination enough to
see the truth needful things a town full
of idiot adults just
falling for it any kid would have
sniffed out leland gaunt and brian rusk
did and look where that got him but
that's the point kids have that
superpower of perception i always like
that stephen king illustrates that and
as this was the movie that terrified me
this was in fact my jaw not only did i
see this before i saw jaws but it was
more likely that a werewolf was going to
kill me than a shark like jaws
was intense but it never scared me as
much a silver bullet this movie is very
near and dear to my heart you're getting
a peek into my soul with this video
because after watching jaws i was always
like all right well i live in the great
northwest i live in washington
also i didn't live near the ocean
however lived around the forest and
trees so at night when i would look into
the deep dark blackness of the woods i'd
be like
yep werewolf territory i still say it's
more likely that a werewolf would kill
me in the northwest
than a great white shark i just that's
real to me i still when i look into the
woods i get this uneasy feeling it's
probably because of this movie silver
bullet excels when it is being jaws and
that is when you don't see the creature
that's when silver bullets at its
scariest that's when it's at its most
intense you know it just
has the pov camera that shaky cam that
makes it feel
different than the rest of the movie you
hear the snarling of the werewolf really
scary intense stuff was when you don't
see the wolf that it's at its most
intense
couple of werewolf transformation scenes
really horrific imagery i like those but
at the end when the movie starts getting
more brash it's like okay now you can
see the wolf
it's just not as scary you're like ah
you just look like a guy in a thin
bear outfit well that's not scary seeing
the shark in jaws never compromises the
feeling of jaws seeing the werewolf and
silver bullet it does compromise silver
bullet but i really liked revisiting
silver bullet as i was
watching silver bullet this time around
i was like yeah
this is something kids probably
shouldn't watch at least a kid in the
late 80s
shouldn't watch this i don't know i mean
kids can go on youtube right now and see
let's play videos gameplay videos of
mortal kombat they can go on
youtube and see any number of clips from
any gruesome horror movies
i didn't have such access are you
kidding me so when silver bullet crossed
my plate i was like
i'm fundamentally changed forever bless
my parents they tried they tried their
best to get me not to watch things like
this but
whenever they were occupied i knew
i had the tv guide i enjoy watching it
and even watching it this time around i
i was really hooked by it and it's the
stephen king town the stephen king-esque
execution
gary busey and corey haim that all works
for me when you don't see the werewolf
this movie's actually
a great werewolf movie it just it ends
very abruptly you know i don't know if
the book ends this abruptly
it probably does because it ends kind of
like a book but a movie should kind of
pad the ending to give the audience time
to kind of decompress from the
experience like if you look at the book
the martian
it ends pretty abruptly after mark
watney is rescued in the movie
it has that whole extra scene where he's
on earth and he's giving a lecture it
just gives the audience more time
to go okay we're breathing we're
decompressing we're
all right now we can go back to the
world i think silver bullet could have
used a scene like that but just didn't
have that subjectively to me i love
silver bullet and for a first time watch
if you've never seen it it's fun to be
like
who's the werewolf and i think silver
bull is a good time no alcohol required
all right so silver bullet have you seen
it what did you think about it did you
see it back in the day have you seen it
recently does it hold up
or what's your favorite werewolf story
whatever it is whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more
click right here to see more
you